[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY SUSSMAN:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We host these webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Jeremy Sussman.
I'm a product manager
on Google Docs.
And today, I'll be talking
to you about tips and tricks
to boost productivity
on Google Docs.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform.
We have Googlers standing
by to answer them.
This talk is a quick
overview of Google Docs.
If you want to learn more,
please visit the G Suite
Learning Center.
We'll give you a link
at the end of the talk.
OK.
Let's get started.
Sorry.
I'm having technical troubles.
OK.
Sorry about that.
One of the most common
things you do at work
is to write documents.
You might write a proposal,
a technical specification
document, a legal
contract, or even
use a document to
capture meeting notes.
In this talk,
we're going to walk
through the typical
lifecycle of a document that
often goes something like this.
You kick off the document by
copying an existing document
or removing the information.
You then add in
other information
that you have on hand.
You then share the document
with your teammates
and stakeholders,
some of whom may
be external to your company,
to build up the content.
Once you've gotten
all the information
you need in the document,
you go through it all again
and add that extra
level of polish.
And finally, you send
your document out
to its intended audience.
In this presentation,
I'm going to highlight
how Google Docs saves you
time during each of these four
steps.
OK.
Let's talk about
starting a new document.
As I said, often when
starting a new document,
people will make a copy
of an existing document,
remove all the old content, and
then start adding new content.
Although this is a
very common practice,
it is not the most efficient.
A better way to do this
is by using templates.
A template is basically a
common outline of a document.
It removes the time spent
copying and cleaning up
old files in the
workplace, giving you
more time for the
important creative work.
With the Custom
Template feature,
you can create a
template from any file
and then submit it to
the template gallery
for your coworkers to
adapt and use as needed.
G Suite for Business
and Education customers
can restrict who can
submit new templates
or require templates to be
approved by an administrator
before they appear
in the gallery.
Finding templates across
a big organization
can be time consuming
and often impossible.
With the Template
Gallery in Google Docs,
organizations can distribute
their up-to-date templates
and group them by team.
A template that is
custom to your team
allows you to focus less
on formatting and more
on driving impact and
achieving success.
We talked about starting
off from a template
and customizing it to
produce your end result.
But what if you need to produce
10 very similar documents?
In certain job functions,
like sales, there's
a common workflow where
you send similar documents
to many customers.
This is a
time-consuming process.
For each customer, you
make a copy of the template
and then edit the name of
the customer and the data
about the customer.
You have to do that
one customer at a time.
But with Google
Docs, it will soon
be possible to automate this
process using our Application
Programming Interface, or API.
These APIs are built
for reading and writing
presentations,
spreadsheets, and documents
from your application.
The REST API for Docs is
currently in developer preview.
REST APIs work
really well if you
have an on-premise or
a legacy data store
you need to work with.
It's a nice way to integrate
with a cloud-based product
like G Suite even if you aren't
fully on the cloud just yet.
We built this API because
of a wide-ranging need
to support several core
use cases, specifically,
bulk document creation, content
management, and workflow
management.
For example, you
could create a program
that runs on your
existing infrastructure,
reads from an on-premise
system, and pushes data out
into a Docs template.
This could automate the sales
scenario I just mentioned,
for example.
Or you could add an
Export to Docs button
on an internal site.
This could push the data
on the page to a document
where you can get the benefit
of our collaborative editing
capabilities.
Now you have Docs editors right
where you need them no matter
what tool you're using.
As I mentioned, the
REST API for Docs
is currently in
developer preview.
You can sign up for early access
at developers.google.com/docs.
So templates give
you a head start
with formatting the layout.
But is there a way
to get a head start
on the content of your document?
Often, you have a lot
of existing work--
the information in
other docs, slides,
or spreadsheets that form the
basis of your new document.
We want to help you easily
find that information.
Docs Explore uses
artificial intelligence
to suggest relevant
files for you.
It does this based on
your previous Drive
activity and information
in your documents.
This allows you to find the
most up-to-date information
and create new material quickly.
You can also search manually for
files, emails, or even the web
for more content.
Just click the Explore icon at
the bottom right of your screen
to benefit from
this great feature.
Often, the information in a
document, especially charts
and tables, comes
from a spreadsheet.
If the information in the
original chart or table
changes, it can be
difficult to remember
to update copies of those charts
or tables in other documents.
And it can be tedious and
time-consuming when you do.
To save you valuable
time, you could
choose to link charts and tables
that come from spreadsheets.
If you do that, we will remind
you that the data has changed.
And we make it possible
to update your chart
with a single click without ever
needing to leave your document
or presentation.
This way, you maintain a single
source of truth and update
content and new documents
with the click of a button.
This can be great to keep the
data in important documents
evergreen.
Similarly, it is often useful
to embed a slide in a document.
Like charts or
tables, slides can
be linked, ensuring that
they too remain up to date.
There is another document
starting aid that's
coming soon to Google Docs.
The G Suite Quick
Access side panel
that appears in
Gmail today will soon
be available in Google Docs.
So how is this useful
for starting a doc?
Well, for example,
if you know there's
a document you'll
need to write, you
could outline it in Google
Keep using lightweight notes
while you're on the go.
Then, when you sit down to
write the actual document,
you can use the G
Suite side panel
to get started by just dragging
and dropping your notes
from Keep into the document.
With the G Suite
side panel, you can
use the full power
of the G Suite tools
without having to navigate
a lot of open windows.
Finally, we built
an even cooler way
to get a head start on a
specific type of document--
meeting notes.
Research has
demonstrated that agendas
are widely beneficial
for creating
efficient,
high-quality meetings.
Tracking agendas and
capturing action items
make meetings more
productive and effective.
Here's a sneak peek at a
new feature of Google Docs--
Quick Meeting Notes.
Quick Meeting Notes integrate
with Google's Calendar
to help attendees quickly
setup meeting note documents.
It makes tracking
agendas, notes,
and action items easy
with a simple template
to keep meetings
more productive.
We'll talk more about action
items in a few minutes.
OK.
So in step one, you save time
by starting from a template
and quickly adding information
from other sources,
like charts, tables, and slides.
Now that you have a
good starting point,
you're ready to bring
your teammates in
to collaborate on the document.
This is where Google
Docs really shines.
Let's see how this is done.
With all Google documents
being in the cloud,
you don't send your
collaborators a copy.
At no point do you need to
label a document as version one,
send it out to others and
then wait for the next version
to be emailed back to you while
you sit there unproductively
wondering what your
colleagues are doing.
What you see on this
screen is how collaboration
works in Google Docs.
Multiple people are
making multiple changes
all in real time.
Even if your colleagues
work in different time zones
and in different
parts of the world,
you all work on
the same document.
Never again will you have
to deal with this version
roulette, because everyone is
working on the exact same file.
People nowadays often
work on-the-go while
commuting to the office or
traveling on a business trip.
The real-time
collaboration features
are all available on our
apps, on iOS, and on Android.
Sometimes it can take dozens of
edits to make a document just
right, especially a legal
agreement, project proposal,
or research paper.
To reduce the
messiness of it all,
collaborators can
suggest changes.
This feature stores
their changes
for review instead of
changing the content directly.
You can then look
through the suggestions
and approve or reject
each one as you see fit.
And as with collaboration,
suggested changes
are part of our mobile apps.
With Google Docs,
you can also name
versions of a document,
preview clean versions,
and both accept or
reject all changes.
Named versions of
a document allow
you to assign custom
names to specific versions
of your document.
This is a great way to
keep a historical record
of your team's progress.
It's also helpful for
communicating when
a document is actually final.
Previewing clean
versions of a document
allows you to see
what your Doc would
look like without the
comments or suggested edits.
Finally, both
acceptance or rejection
of all edit suggestions
means you or your teammates
don't have to review every
single punctuation mark
or formatting update.
With one click, you can bring
the document to the version
that you want.
The collective power
of a team can help
to get things done quickly.
But effective
teams generate lots
of to-dos and action items,
which can be hard to track.
Google Docs makes collaboration
easier with comments and action
items and can even suggest
action items automatically.
Comments in Google Docs
allow your team members
to leave suggestions or
notes on what to edit or add.
Other editors working
on the document
can see and respond to comments.
This is the magic of Google
Docs collaboration come to life.
Action items in
Google Docs allow
you to assign tasks to others.
You can assign an action
item manually to someone
by mentioning their
name in a comment
and checking the
Action Item box.
The assignee will get
an email notification
to see the action item.
And they will see them clearly
highlighted with a blue bar
when they open the file.
And with suggested
action items, Google Docs
identifies potential
to-dos, and smartly
suggests turning them into
actual assigned to-dos
for easy tracking.
So on desktop, for example,
if you type phrases like,
when to follow up on the
keynote script, or [INAUDIBLE]
to schedule a weekly
check in, Docs
will intelligently
suggest an action item
to assign to a person based on
natural language processing.
Sometimes when you
are collaborating
with an external agency,
they don't use Google Docs.
Whether you are negotiating
a contract with a client
or coordinating a sales
agreement with a supplier
chances are, you might have
to deal with multiple file
formats.
In Google Drive, you can
comment on those files
the way you're used
to in Google Docs.
No need to open up
other tools to get
the collaborative
benefit of Google Docs.
In the Drive Preview pane,
comment, assign tasks,
or mention coworkers on
any file, and the people
you work with can reply back.
This is true even if
they're not using G Suite.
Let's say your coworker
opens a file on her Windows
laptop using Microsoft Word.
She'll see your
comment in the file
and can reply right from there.
The ability to comment
in Drive Preview mode
is just one example of
the interoperability
between G Suite and
Microsoft Office products.
For some documents, in
addition to collaborators,
you might also have
stakeholders or approvers.
You may need to get your
proposal or contract approved
by stakeholders in various
functions like legal or PR.
Without G Suite, you'd probably
download the document as PDF,
and then use a product
tracking tool to collect formal
approvals and sign-offs--
OK.
Sure, that works.
But if any of the approvers asks
for a change in the contract
or presentation, you
need to make that change,
produce a new PDF,
somehow differentiate
that version from the first
one, and then resend it
for approval.
And as I said earlier,
version roulette is a hassle.
With G Suite, this
approval workflow
is a whole lot more streamlined.
We recently announced
Drive's upcoming
document-centric
workloads feature,
which will allow users
to get formal approvals
on their files.
With this feature, you
submit a file for approval
from specific coworkers.
And upon doing so, the file
gets locked and shared,
and the approvers get notified.
After the document is approved,
the file stays locked.
And anybody looking
at the file will
be able to tell that the
file had been approved.
This lightweight workflow
tool can powerfully
streamline company
processes and will soon
be available in an
early-adopters program.
For this type of approval
or sign-off process,
when you have many
stakeholders, it's
helpful to be able to
track their progress.
Google Docs offers the ability
to audit collaborator activity.
The Activity
Dashboard allows you
to see which collaborators have
viewed your document and when.
You can understand
which of your teammates
have seen your latest
revision and who
needs to be notified that
they need to stay in the loop.
Google Docs gives you
the power to track
the progress on a project
with lots of moving parts.
OK.
We've talked about
starting your document
and collecting
information with others.
And we talked
about collaborating
around that document.
What does Google do
to help you save time
with a fine-grained
copy and polish?
One feature in Google
Docs that helps
you get to that level of
polish is our Default Textiles
feature.
Google Docs allows you
to set up custom title
and heading styles.
With custom styles,
you get formatting
that matches your
company's brand
or your own personal style.
This makes it easy for you
to keep that level of polish
you want without expending
a lot of extra energy.
Fonts matter for polish too.
There are some that
are good for documents
that are read on
a personal screen,
while others are good
for the big screen.
You can choose from
hundreds of fonts
provided by Google Slides.
We recently expanded
the font catalog
to support 62 languages
including non-Latin scripts
like Cyrillic and Devanagari.
Once you find
fonts you like, you
can add them to
your My Fonts list.
Once they're in
this list, they will
be available for quick access
in the Font dropdown menu
on all of your Docs files.
We found, in our
user research, there
are three top cases
where people worry
the most about the
quality of their writing.
In high stakes internal
communications,
when you're drafting
communications
that will drive key
business decisions,
in external collaboration when
you're drafting a document
or proposal with the
intention of sharing
this outside of your company,
and when you're collaborating
as a non-native
speaker, when you're not
the native speaker of
the official language
of your company or industry.
In all these cases,
it's critical to ensure
that your writing is correct.
We are introducing grammar
suggestions in Google Docs
along with a revamped interface
to your spelling and grammar
review.
These new features build
on the existing spell check
functionality to also highlight
possible grammar errors
in your text and help
you correct them.
This will help you spend less
time checking and proofreading
your work and make your
writing easier to understand.
Google Docs uses machine
learning technology
to recognize and help
correct potential grammar
errors in real time.
When Docs detects a
possible grammar correction,
it will underline it
in blue to indicate
you might want to check it.
You can then right-click to
see a suggested correction
or dismiss the alert.
Possible grammar
errors will also
show up when you run a
Spelling and Grammar Check
through the Tools menu.
These features will
initially launch
as an early-adopter program.
Another place to find polishing
help is in the add-on store.
Here you can find
rich integrations
to help you build more
powerful documents.
For example, you
can add diagrams
you created in programs outside
of G Suite like in Lucid Chart.
Or you can more easily generate
bibliographies and citations
using the EasyBib add-on.
Explore the add-on store for
a variety of helpful tools.
OK.
So we've created the document.
We've worked with
our collaborators.
We've gotten the
approvals needed.
Everything's polished
and buttoned up.
And now we're ready
to send out our work.
How does Google Docs
help you in this phase
of creating a document?
When it comes to documents
in the enterprise world,
security matters.
When there is extra sensitive
information in a document,
you want to be conservative
about what the recipients can
do with the file.
For example, you may give some
stakeholders view-only access.
This prevents them from
changing their own access level
and allowing other new people
to be able to access the file.
You can also prevent
downloading or making
a copy of the document.
This type of protection
is not possible in a world
where you attach files in an
email for others to download
and forward at their will.
To keep your organization's
information extra safe
in these situations,
you can also
set an expiration date
for specific user access
to files in Google Docs.
For instance,
imagine your business
hires an outside contractor for
a project lasting three months.
To complete that
job, the contractor
needs to view a
document containing
confidential information
about your company.
You share the document
containing this information
with the contractor.
Give them view access
only, and set that access
to expire when their contract
does in three months.
Now, if the contractor
attempts to open the document
after the expiration
date has passed,
they'll be denied access.
Google Docs strives to
give you full control
over how your files are shared.
And this is all done with a few
clicks in a self-explanatory
user interface.
Google Docs also
gives you a choice
on how you want to
share your document.
While the easiest
and most common way
is to share the file natively,
with the right access controls,
as I just mentioned, you
might want to share it
in a different format.
You can see here
the various formats
into which you can
export your final product
without losing any formatting.
With Google Docs, all the
phases of creating a document,
getting started, collaborating,
polishing, and sharing
are easier and more efficient.
In this talk we've taken you
through a bunch of great Google
Docs features--
custom templates in the
template gallery, developer
APIs to generate
documents, explore
and suggested data,
linked charts,
tables, and slides
that remain up to date.
The Quick Access side
panel, quick Meeting Notes,
collaboration with comments
and action items manually
or automatically suggested,
suggested changes
and the ability to bulk
accept or reject them,
named versions and
clean previews,
approvals and sign-offs in
Google Docs or on other formats
via Google Drive, an Activity
Dashboard to monitor approval
workflows, default text
formatting and more fonts,
spelling and grammar
improvements, add-ons--
and many security
features including
limited access rights,
exploration, and exporting.
That's a lot of
information to take in.
If you want to learn
more about Google Docs
or review some of the
things we've discussed here,
learn more today by visiting
the G Suite Learning
Center at the link
shown on your screen.
OK.
Stay tuned for live Q&A. We'll
be back in less than a minute.
Hi.
Welcome back.
We've gotten a number of
questions from the audience.
And now we will answer them.
So the first
question says, "That
doesn't keep people from making
copies of a document, though.
Right?"
This refers to the
security feature
where we disable copying.
What that does is it
disables the file copy
entry in the menu.
And therefore, people cannot
make copies through that
mechanism.
Second question.
"Can I share a document I make
in Google Docs with someone
without a G Suite account?"
Absolutely.
When you send out
a document by link,
people who click
on that link will
be able to see your document.
A G Suite account
is not necessary.
Third question.
"When I share the document,
can the other person
know all the previous
versions and comments?"
This depends on how
you share the document.
If you share it
in view-only mode,
the person will not see
comments or previous versions.
If you share it in
edit mode, then they
will be able to
see those things.
Next, "How do I limit
access to a document
so only people at
my company see it?"
By default, when you
create a document,
you choose who can see it.
So if you choose to let people
outside of the company see it,
then you are giving them
explicit permission.
But documents, by
default, are only
limited to the people you have
expressly given access to.
Finally, "Can I link to a
specific part of a document?"
Absolutely.
One of the features in
Google is the Bookmark.
And you can insert a bookmark
at any point in the document.
And then you can link directly
to that point in the document
itself.
I believe that's all
the questions we have.
So that's all for today.
Please tune in next Tuesday
for the next Google Cloud OnAir
webinar.
And thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]